now meanwhile back in the swamp in d.c
our u.s supreme court justices they're
probably probably likely pretty restless
tonight because 24 hours ago a man that
was armed with a nine-millimeter handgun
and a knife traveled from california to
maryland to the home of justice brett
kavanaugh and that's where he planned to
assassinate the supreme court justice
and then commit suicide this lunatic who
is now in police custody thankfully
great job for the police was reportedly
upset over the leaked draft roe versus
wade opinion he knew exactly where
kavanaugh lived why because democrats
were publishing uh his address and the
address of other justices online
liberals have been protesting outside of
kavanaugh's home on and off now for
weeks including another demonstration
earlier tonight only moments ago but of
course for years the left has well
brutally and unfairly they have vilified
justice kavanaugh quite unfairly but
without any corroborating evidence they
falsely accused him remember let's see
of gang rape then they told people that
he was an abusive alcoholic a drug
addict that hated all women over msdnc
that would be nbc news joy reid
published a conspiracy theory that
kavanaugh was trying to ban birth
control and top senate democrat chuckie
schumer even seemingly threatened
kavanaugh's life at a speech that he
gave right on the steps of the u.s
supreme court you probably remember this
i want to tell you gorsuch i want to
tell you kavanaugh you have released the
whirlwind and you will pay the price
you won't know what hit you if you go
forward with these awful decisions
i want to tell you cavanaugh gorsuch you
have released the war when you will pay
the price you won't know what hit you
now naturally a few weeks ago schumer
didn't seem to mind at all the
kavanaugh's address and other supreme
court justices addresses were published
online and that so-called protesters
showed up outside of his house he does
have young children in a family now
schumer thought it was kind of hilarious
take a look
are you comfortable with the protests
that we saw outside the homes of supreme
court justices over the weekend if
protests are peaceful yes
my house is there's protests three four
times a week outside my house that's the
the american way to peacefully protest
is okay and i've been that's my wife
sorry
um
maybe there's a protest outside
i doubt uh chuck schumer's home is uh
having protests three or four times a
week not only did schumer refuse to
condemn this kind of intimidation this
type of harassment but so did biden's
white house take a look at this so i
know that there's an outrage right now i
guess about
protests that have been peaceful to date
and we certainly continue to encourage
that outside of judges homes some of
these justices have young kids but their
neighbors are not all public figures so
would the president think about waving
off activists that want to go into
residential neighborhoods in virginia
and maryland
peter look i think our view here is that
peaceful protest there's a long history
in the united states in the country of
that so he doesn't care if they're
protesting outside the supreme court or
outside someone's private residence i
don't have an official u.s government
position on where people protest
now one blue checkmark media mob
reporter took it even a step further
tweeting quote may these people never
know a moment of peace or safety until
they rot in the ground one politician
from california encouraging protesters
to quote empty kavanaugh's house and
burn his bleep in front of him in a
statement house speaker nancy pelosi she
even applauded the quote righteous anger
against kavanaugh and called on her
supporters to march and mobilize now for
months she blocked a bipartisan bill
bolstering security for all nine supreme
court justices aren't these the same
people saying insurrection every other
second of the day now she continues to
block security for our supreme court
justices and this bill to this very day
uh why nancy why are you blocking what
is a bipartisan bill to keep judges safe
why didn't you call up the national
guard by the way now that we're talking
about it that donald trump authorized
days earlier
for you on january 6 because i doubt
that committee is ever going to ask you
because they have a predetermined
outcome and keep in mind for the past
several weeks this country has
experienced an increasing level of
violence against those that oppose
abortion look for example in buffalo
yesterday one pregnancy center it was
actually fire bombed in asheville north
carolina another crisis pregnancy center
was vandalized overnight windows broken
graffiti that read quote if abortions
aren't safe neither are you we recently
saw a similar attack that was in a
clinic in wisconsin and yet nancy pelosi
is blocking a bill that would step up
security for these justices who might
soon overturn roe v wade really and just
to recap the party that claims to revere
our great institutions the democratic
party they first vilified then they
smeared a u.s supreme court justice then
many call for violence against him
you won't know what hit you right and
then someone perhaps one of their
lackeys inside the supreme court leaked
the court's abortion decision or at
least a draft of one in an unprecedented
effort to unleash an angry mob against
the court and then they lied about what
the decision would mean to whip up their
base in a frenzy with full of just lies
of misinformation and propaganda because
if roe v wade is overturned abortion
will not be illegal in america it will
be
relegated and regulated by the states in
other words it's not enumerated as a
right in the constitution then the 10th
amendment kicks in the states decide
then democrats publish the home
addresses of these supreme court
justices online then they refuse to pass
a bill bolstering their security and
then a deranged lunatic shows up at
kavanaugh's front door in order to
assassinate him
look despite all of this
i'm not blaming democrats for the
actions of this crazy individual just
like i didn't blame them when a rachel
maddow obsessed bernie sanders superfan
shot up a baseball field full of
republican lawmakers nearly killing
steve scalise that day i hold the people
responsible for their own actions but
for god's sakes as joe always says can
democrats at least quit their obnoxious
moral preening and could they give these
people the protection they need every
official should be protected republican
democrat whether they work in the halls
of congress or at the supreme court at
least well that's what we believe on
this show democrats only seem to care
about political violence when they can
then use it to their political advantage
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else